on va revenir sur cette saison de koh
lanta qui a été marqué par énormément de
moments marquants et vous allez bien sûr
réagir aussi chez vous l'élimination
claude nawal méritait la victoire
inès mérite et elle donne au final on
numéro 10 dès le premier prime il s'est
passé quelque chose de ouf
avant on avait jugé au niveau de la nash
maintenant on à ahmad ahmad c'est un
candidat
le mec il est déterminé et il vient
c'est le seul cas il vient à kolontar
mais il se dit pas je vais quand même
essayer de voir comment je nage avant
c'est c'est koh lanta voilà c'est quand
même il ya beaucoup d'eau quoi quand
même non non il y va je sais pas nager
mais c'est pas bon on verra sur place
vous verra mais c'est déjà dur pour la
bad qui appréhendent la nage en mer
[Musique]
hommage à jacques
amag ne peut maîtriser sa peur de l'eau
incroyable il décide d'abandonner malade
qu'est ce qui s'est passé j'ai pas
réussi gecko maximum sachant que vous
aviez pied jusqu'à la cage jusqu'à la
cage oui ça doit vous avez pied alors ça
c'est d'un grand moment est ce que est
ce que pour vous nawal méritait de
gagner ou est ce que c'était que l'audit
la vérité parler sans détour oui
ah oui vraiment autant je suis triste
que ça ne soit pas allée plus loin
autant lawal honnêtement elle a vraiment
planer sur plein d'épreuves qu'elle
avait un peu comme au féminin une niaque
mais alors qu'ils ne lâchent jamais
lasser au mot chapeau 10h20 c'est un
petit format lgv à paris d'ici mais
l'exceptionnel
alors ils ont ils ont bûché la niaque je
fais pas été bien sûr elle n'est que je
fais pas que l'on est à blâmer c'est
comme si tu faisais koh-lanta sait pas
nager la brasse exceptionnel abad oui
mais voilà mais évidemment que c'est lui
qui devait gagner
il a hésité médicaux de lever willow de
l'histoire de koh lanta c'est vrai qu'a
menée le plus d'épreuves la gagne 10
était prête et il a gagné tout terrain à
la fin ils avaient l'unité un collier à
collier de perles en verre une
bijouterie harry s'est lui offert la
bijouterie koh lanta la guinée j'étais
déçu mais les potences et pas de l'adcf
et alors elle à la jeunesse elle est
tombée en 3d elle tombe en première ou
si elle a pas eu au final mais bon on
n'a pas gagné une s guinness d'accord
elle a été choisie c'est moi je suis
d'accord avec kiel à moi j'adore cloud
voilà franchement je suis fou de lui
j'ai même mis twitté pour luxe mais
alors il n'a pas été éliminé par le
conseil il a été éliminé parce qu'il est
tombé des poteaux minois mais il est
tombé sur une épreuve aurait pu être
repêché c'est lui le vrai vainqueur en
fait claude le vrai vainqueur
cela dit ce sont tous des personnalités
assez incroyable moi je suis très
admiratif
merci en tout cas très belle
intervention non vraiment super ça c'est
génial un bruit sopi l'épreuve des
poteaux quand même j'ai remarqué ça
avantage les petits pieds non et non
d'aller en fonction de leur pointure
bien sûr mais maryvonne il donne la
mesure du truc et 10 et 23 sur 16 c'est
durant ces neuf voix de nîmes a toujours
dit non
non je n'essaie bien foutus de ma gueule
ap ap hp pour tous il est resté 9 heures
sur les peaux de vous passiez les
poteaux en fonction des fois tu n'as
calculant sa pointure donc forcément tu
le voyais et vaciller comme ça j'avais
de la peine corriveau
moi j'aurais aimé tu viens effectivement
mais nawel je trouve qu'elle a une
histoire de vie incroyable c'est une
battante
je suis ravi qu'elle ait gagné bon là
l'organisme en numéro 9 on va revenir
sur tes weir à lui comme claude il est
adoré des téléspectateurs c'est vrai on
aime beaucoup et on se souvient aussi de
son cri de guerre
c'est une grosse d'arc à regarder vous
êtes de retour dans l'aventuré vous
appartenait maintenant à cette équipe
jaune et pour signer ce retour
quelle force vous avez envie de donner à
votre nouvelle équipe
tout nous est taillée
tant de l'iphone au mal et à tous
vous a fait une orbe airs de broadway ce
droit tout à l'heure mais pas ici à une
force car oui c'est beau ça vient du
coeur comme ça les fait ça se voit vous
allez voir moi je le papier que vous
allez recevoir ça venir du ko alors on
va dire sur koh lanta bien sûr sur cette
finale qui a fait énormément parler le
succès de koh lanta carton de cette
année mérite quoi à quoi vous à quoi
c'est dû
qu'on va les rayer mois confinement je
pense que le confinement on mangeait
très honnêtement je n'aurais pas
regarder cette saison bah si je n'étais
pas à la maison et voilà il y en a plein
qui ont raccroché les wagons pendant le
conflit ni sac te manger raccrocher le
truc et j ai je me suis attaché je suis
resté et j'ai été jusqu'au bout vous
étiez attachés je suis venu à l'hémicyle
oui oui moi je pense confinement excusez
moi je vous dérange
non je pense que vous avez à part les
abeilles confinement moi j'y crois aussi
après il ya eu une baisse qui a fait
beaucoup parler aux débats et eti mayola
ce que moi je suis seul bourricot qui
regardent pas à kolontar où je ne me
regarde pas de collants et à 14 heures
14 heures claude il était déjà en tête--
on parlait déjà de claude à cadenasser
tout ça c'est rare mais c'est quoi ce
tag regarde il se passe un truc deux
fois vaudrait sérieux et moi je pense
que c'est ça le et si oui qu'est eu un
engouement incroyable ajoute claude oui
il a expliqué claude il a expliqué
pourquoi il était tombé des poteaux il
argué y regarder un objectif loin devant
lui et quand ils ont enlevé le une
partie du haut du poteau il s'est
déconcentré l'a perdue d'équilibré des
tombes et c'est ça ouais voilà c'est fou
parce qu'il faut rester faut avoir une
concentration extrême comme vous et vous
aime et que vous entendez tout le temps
lié à ben voyons qu'est ce qu'elle est
belle c'est la vie valait rien moi je
pense que claude le fait qu'il est il
n'est pas gagné cette saison donc c'est
dommage pour lui parce qu'effectivement
il a surnagé toute la saison à bas bruit
sur les énormes à matt bell dans sa
répartie devant la caméra il a été
énorme mais le fait qu'il n'ait pas
gagné et que ça soit sa troisième saison
d'affilée eh ben pour moi la production
de koh lanta et son vainqueur parce qu'à
mon avis claude va revenir à la raison
et du coup les spectateurs ils seront
encore là pour voir et c'est bien sûr
gagne et du cou et lui larry gagner et
là également
comme federer à roland garros tant qu'il
n'avait pas gagné on a envie de le voir
il a dit déjà qu'il était partant qu'il
pourrait signer pour une prochaine
saison et son ticket et le fera oui
bonsoir info claude devrait faire koh
lanta avec booder tome lem miss france
et commissaire devrait faire son bail à
la bouder bouder de kolontar gilbert
julia haut salat à bouder dans koh lanta
la jv sûr et certain regard des douanes
c'est exceptionnel
on va maintenant revenir moi c'est ma
préférée avec laudun je vous le dis
voilà c'est inès elle est en finale de
koh lanta elle aussi fap a fait parler
d'elle pour son caractère est une amère
voilà et c'est vrai que voyager avec un
vrai casse toutes les infirmières tous
les infirmiers qui nous regarde et on se
souvient de 2 en brouille avec moussa et
avec claude et c'est vrai que claude
alors attention hein
claude il est très aimé des
téléspectateurs mais comme m'a dit
damien verseront un journalisme elle a
que deux journalistes rire limani il
n'était pas très mine doit aussi parler
s'il aurait peut-être perdu s'il avait
été en finale contre na wallace ici si
je reconnaissais sombernon pas du tout
est pas tout le monde dit qu'il aurait
perdue contre nadal
apparemment rigide absolument me wade à
voile est trés trés et mais attention
elle était très ordinaire en interne il
ya eu des bizzbee moussa beaucoup plus
fédéré que claude on en pense qu'on veut
mais claude c'est vrai par son art il
est exceptionnel ah oui oui mais du
point de vue des candidats certains ont
jugé qu'il est parce qu il est trop fort
exactement et ben c'est ça ouais mais il
voulait le faire perdre absolument à
mériter il a été énorme
alors regardez inès qui s'embrouille
avec moussa et avec l'autre inès j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes toujours dans
le même état d'esprit
j'ai pas réussi quoi
j'ai envie de d'encastrer claude j'ai
envie de changer de péter un câble lâche
tient là bas je vais te mettre in situ
continue là ça va très bien sûr de ton
côté des vendeurs de paris tu m'écoutes
pas quand je te vois aussi un port du
voile à gibier j'ai juste attirer te dis
pas de surfer et même ça c'est
insupportable c'est pas possible
hélas hélas on ne peut s'empêcher
d'imaginer tous chez nous l'armée témoin
la boule a juste de d'imaginer bouder
dans l'épreuve de l'amour n'est pas
celle d'un koh lanta franchement moi je
signe tout de suite ou pas j'ai dit
pourquoi il devrait faire un format avec
que des charlots s'appellera coloma amir
est le dr mal franchement ça serait
exceptionnel c'est aussi alors là il s
est enquis est arrivé en finale il est
mérité pour inès quand même une
aventurière incroyable fallait elle a
pas gagné d'épreuve l1 ouais mais oui
mais bon mais de toute façon quoi qu'on
en dise des uns ou des autres
ils sont arrivés en finale ça veut dire
qu'une injure et d'y être mais puis
c'est tout ça veut dire que par un biais
ou par un autre un jour par la stratégie
un jour par leurs efforts physiques
ils ont ils ont été au bout de la de
l'aventuré au bout de l'horreur est
question de chance nous ça aurait très
bien pu être j'adore me sens bien qu'ils
soient en finale moussa ben justement
moussa koussa formidable il ya une
grosse rigolade avec moussa et nawal on
l'avait vu la semaine dernière lors de
l'épreuve d'orientation alors à
travailler à ce stade de la compétition
déjà c'est exceptionnel arrivé voilà
mais ne pas perdre sa balise et surtout
savoir lire une boussole il faut quand
même le faire avant d'aller au kolontar
attends tu parles de ça la force de lui
en repères amer moi je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec toi nawel à l'esprit
confus elle n'est plus sûr de rien elle
ne sait même pas si c'est la bonne route
ou pas alors que si moussa et naouel ont
tous les deux vu la balise mais moussa
ne la retrouve pas et naouel a perdu sa
boussole il se fait on aime à boussens
peur moussa lui lie la boussole à
l'envers et part donc vers le nord
[Musique]
je la trouvais la weltwoche
[ __ ] merde ça voilà oui gens disent je
veux rappeler quelque chose je rappelle
quand même que sina où elle a trouvé ça
brille c'est en grande partie grâce à
claude qui lui a donné où il fallait
aller à erevan été remercié elle a
illuminé mais bon allez à willem à
suivre alors justement justement sam
merci isabelle l'un des candidats
qu'elle plus marqué cette édition c'est
sam
et oui et c'était le benjamin de cette
saison et la ville avec l'offre le gars
savait tout faire je vous le dis mais le
problème c'est qu'il est un petit peu un
souci à l'arrogant la jeunesse mais bon
il était très fort un regard des sam
c'était ça devrait être seul sur une île
comme romain sow être seuls les faire
suer
[Musique]
maintenant j'ai un peu levé le pied je
veux qu'ils prennent leurs
responsabilités et qu'ils entretiennent
je vais pas tout faire non plus tout
seul donc j'avoue que la pluie ça me
dérange pas on est à koh lanta on n'est
pas des bisounours on fait pour être
honnête à grozny la récompense je m'en
fous moi ce que je voulais c'est gagné
et ça c'est la plus grande récompense
c'est une nouvelle fois la flèche noire
pour la quatrième fois ça vous vous êtes
le meilleur
ce fut un grand garçon tu sais le faire
tu coupes départ comme ça claque là tu
es tu ou botaniques
merci c'était incroyable pour moi c'est
qu'on va être capable beaucoup de bruit
sur koh lanta wanderers c'est vrai que
ça ce que le casting est bon et que
c'est pas des gens il a peut-être pas
tellement l'idée
moi je suis d'accord mais c'est très
favoris mais ça se ressent qui
récompense aussi pour le sort et on
aurait eu des fuites se seraient ceux ci
y avait des bagarres dans koh lanta ce
serait un signe non mais c'est vrai que
les gars sont gilles des infos en
revanche après il ya beaucoup
d'inimitiés ah oui à des candidats bien
sûr que sur l'île ils font attention à
ses professeurs à roubaix après cultive
des ressentiments conflit a bien su
entre les candidats c'est pas l'harmonie
d'accord alors juste pour dire pour sam
oui super bien fait pour sam parce qu'en
perdant comme ça brut de pomme lui
ménagent l'avenir il va revenir dans pas
long déçu accord c'est super et bah
merci je vous parle aussi d'un autre
candidat régis avril était très critiqué
pour son côté stratège on se souvient
aussi qu'il qui fait balancer des
punchline quand ils voter contre un
aventurier
on a fait une petite compil très fort
aussi cerege j'ai cru comprendre que tu
avais les dents longues
tiens je te propose de rentrer chez toi
que fermer
et celui qui en fait le mois sur le camp
sam un des plus grands opportuniste de
l'histoire française a dit un jour on
peut tout faire avec des baïonnettes
sauf s'asseoir dessus
je te laisse méditer ça avec ton la
tentative d'alliance avorté j'ai juste
envie de te dire va vis et deviens
vraiment il y avait un casting
incroyable mois celui que le seul que je
verrai faire koh lanta ici c'est mon ami
maxime franchement je le verrais bien
longtemps rappelez-vous les poteaux on a
bien sûr été fait raison sur un trottoir
non mais c'est vrai maxime je le verrais
bien oui valérian moi ce que je trouve
dommage dans koh lanta et notamment en
france
c'est que l'aspect stratégique de l'
aventure n'est pas assez valorisée aux
états unis le côté stratégique sotchi
qui font beaucoup de stratégie c'est des
héros et par les téléspectateurs ils
sont ils sont vraiment bien vu en france
c'est pas le cas à mal et je vous
remercie parce que ça fait du bien
d'avoir un spécialiste média non logique
[Rires]
[Musique]
oui je peux ajouter du coup de par
rapport au confinement moi je fais
partie de ceux qui ont raccroché le
programme parce que c'est servait mais à
moitié et du coup j'ai même envoyé ma
candidature
bah voilà il fallait donner mon épaule à
ne pas là tout de suite je vous dis la
vérité elle est super c'est des poteaux
à temps pour le confinement est un gros
cadeau n'est pas demain sur rtl beaucoup
de changements radio en ce moment on va
y revenir sur le départ de sarah elle
avait déjà participé à deux éditions de
koh lanta
elle était connue pour son caractère de
guérir mais elle a dû quitter le jeu
pour rester là et quand elle a appris ça
l était pas bien du tout regardez
regardez c'est ça notre départ sur
décision médicale occasionne le retour
c'était y'a pas traiter que soit sa
situation n'était avant voilà ces deux
jours elle est restée deux jours mejdina
voilà à lédenon mais si la vérité c'est
fait mais votera ce sel il risque
d'avoir des émeutes ration d'année
prochaine aussi bien les proches au
début des nouveaux va rentrer dans le
top 3 des moments forts de la saison
avec inès il est ce que pour quelqu'un
ici c'est son aventurière préféré dit la
vérité maxime mais non pas physiquement
oui alémanique vrai sympa qu'il n'était
pas et n'est pas formaté elle s'en
foutent elle est un peu les pas de
filtre et c'est ce qu'elle voulait et je
suis les gens sont la critique elle s'en
foutait complètement je me l'étais
drôles ou franchement très jolie moi
j'aime beaucoup et est votre préféré
c'était ma préférée d'accord travers ses
couleurs préférées
moi j'aimais bien mais j'aimais bien là
votre préféré oui mon père était
magnifique sur son as tu as as elle se
lâche pas t'en as we have à faire d elle
va faire des films des choses comme ça
elle est magnifique la balle a tardé à
lembras ines
il ya quelques semaines avec un énorme
buzz elle avait révélé qu'elle n'avait
presque jamais manger de fruits
regardez ça va être un truc de
dégustation parce que je connais pas ça
j'ai jamais coûté 2 pastèque
j'aimais goûter de kiwis
ça c'est une orange aussi vous vous
rangez jamais douté j'ai bien fait de
ramener celle là fait découvrir la vie
un wc cas voilà ouais jessica lors il
n'a pas déçu car apparemment jessica
aurait les faveurs des garçons ici
jessica est ce que vous voulez que j'ai
c'est d'inviter jessica pour la fin de
l'année inès inès in essieux inès ses
péchés geci qu'est ce que voulait que
j'ai c'est d'inviter pour la daïra d'ath
venir demain après moi je dis ou la
semaine prochaine
je ne sais pourquoi tu as inès bas les
deux très bien où ça c'est vrai moi
j'aimerais rencontrer cloud j'aimerais
j'espèrais sait jamais peut-être je vais
le rencontrer bientôt un album fatah
match parce que jamais on sait jamais
j'ai peut-être rencontrer on ne sait
jamais quand tu je sais qu'il aimerait
bien vous voir une audi a6 vous aussi
vous allez avoir vous avez pour avoir
envie de me voir l'année prochaine saipa
pression on se souvient aussi du moment
où ahmad annonce à tous le coc que suite
à la réunion des ambassadeurs
c'est delphine qui est éliminée sur le
show a été tellement venerque elle avait
sorti toutes les expressions quotien où
la langue française
regardez le truc c'est qu'il fallait
faire un choix c'était moi ou de vous
mais je suis vraiment vraiment désolé
delphine j'ai fait pour toi
non mais tu arrives à te regarder dans
une glace
brighton à vaincre sans péril on
triomphe sans gloire on n'aura jamais un
cheval de course pourtant je suis pas un
mouton les moutons marchent en troupes
ont les lions marche seul géré par celle
de moundir fatigue la serre et pour nous
l'extrait de koh lanta
cette année c'est joseph il en a parlé
tout à l'heure un bien sûr denis
brogniart s'est il y avait un candidat
donc joseph qui avait fait énormément
parler ni il s'était pris la tête pour
faire le feu et quand il a compris qu'il
allait se faire virer au conseil il a
décidé de l'état simplement c'est fait
c'est vrai c'était son acte fort
regardez regardez jour la déception de
joseph se mue en colère froide il le
veut se venger et éteindre le feu
un acte inédit dans toute l' aventure
koh lanta
atalante soirée vin je suis le feu j'ai
passé trois jours au début
le mec il fait les soulèvements inbev
nicox
[Rires]